y
la ciudad de severodonezk es el foco del
interés internacional por ser en este
momento el foco de los ataques de las
tropas rusas según el kremlin esta
ciudad consolidaría la conquista de la
región del donbass que está conformada
por dos regiones la región de doñetsk y
la región de lugansk para ucrania la
caída de esta ciudad es un punto de
quiebre en el conflicto definiría el
destino de la guerra así lo indicó el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
severodonezk sigue siendo el epicentro
de combates en el donbass como resultado
de ese día y noche ya el día 105 de una
guerra a gran escala estamos defendiendo
nuestras posiciones y estamos
infringiendo pérdidas tangibles al
enemigo esta es una batalla muy brutal
muy dura quizás una de las más difíciles
de toda esta guerra estoy agradecido con
todos y cada uno de los que están
defendiendo en gran medida ahí es donde
se está decidiendo ahora el destino de
nuestro bombas summertime sarsfield
historia de la más otan vas a parte de
esta ofensiva por parte de las tropas
rusas de severodonezk también fue
destacado a lo largo de esta semana esa
reunión entre el canciller ruso sérguei
lávrov y su contraparte turco el señor
mevlüt cavusoglu en la ciudad de ankara
para hablar sobre los temas del bloqueo
de los puertos ucranianos y también el
paso de barcos con cereales y granos a
través de los estrechos turcos el tema
del abastecimiento de granos y de
cereales parece darle una ventaja a
rusia pese a la enorme presión
internacional que hay ante la posible el
posible inicio de una hambruna a nivel
mundial como usar a rusia esta ventaja
desde el parlamento ruso han dicho que
también esperan eso lo anunciaron esta
semana que muy pronto haya una
incorporación a los territorios de la
federación de las zonas de gerzón
donestsk y lugansk estamos entonces ante
un inminente cambio de las fronteras
rusas y también ante la pérdida de
territorio de ucrania tal y como le pasó
en su momento a finlandia cuando se
enfrentó a la unión soviética también
vale la pena analizar el llamado que
hizo el gobierno ucraniano ante el
parlamento europeo en la ciudad de
estrasburgo para acelerar el proceso de
ingreso de ucrania a la unión europea
para que reciba el estatus de país
candidato este estatus en que lo
beneficiaría y por supuesto no podemos
dejar de lado el rearme de alemania que
es un tema que ha causado mucha
preocupación por parte del gobierno ruso
ante lo que pueda suceder en el resto de
europa pues bien para conversar y para
analizar los diferentes hechos sucedidos
a lo largo de las semanas relacionados
con la guerra en ucrania saludamos a la
doctora anne y vélez contreras suárez
ellas analista de asuntos globales y
también es coordinadora de la
licenciatura de negocios globales de la
universidad iberoamericana ella se
conecta a esta hora desde la ciudad de
mexico y también se une a esta
conversación a marcos varias ferreira él
es profesor en estudios rusos y postos
soviéticos en la universidad desde
lisboa se llamen viendo señor farías y
se conecta desde la capital la
portuguesa recuerda que ustedes también
nuestros televidentes hacen parte de
esta conversación estamos a través de
diferentes redes sociales de recuerdo
estamos en facebook en instagram en
twitter y también puede ver nuestra
señal en streaming en youtube nos
encuentran como france24 bajo ese y
arroba sant y logo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 usted ya la conoce
esperamos todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas en torno a este resumen de los
hechos principales los más destacados de
esta semana en torno a la guerra en
ucrania comienzo entonces con nuestro
punto de partida como me gusta llamar a
la primera pregunta para este debate de
salud entonces a la doctora maribel
contreras gracias por acompañarnos a
esta hora y nuestro punto de partida la
importancia de severodonezk que
implicaría para rusia la calidad de esta
ciudad la caída en sus manos me refiero
a nivel militar y que significaría para
ucrania o esto es simplemente otro
episodio más de propaganda rusa de al
anunciar que ya están prontos a capturar
esta ciudad
a contra bastante a un gusto poder estar
aquí contigo con todo tu auditorio
respondiendo a tu atinada pregunta
parece que cada vez que toman una ciudad
la historia y la narrativa es la misma
por un lado el presidente ucraniano pues
dice que no van a permitir esta ofensiva
militar por parte de rusia y por el otro
lado el gobierno ruso dice que ya están
a punto de que ucrania se rinda cada
ciudad a lo largo de estos ya más de 100
días de guerra hemos escuchado en esta
perspectiva a veces hasta contradictoria
donde más bien pareciera que pues esta
narrativa se basa en los intereses de
cada país pero también a veces pareciera
que son cortinas de humo para distraer
la opinión internacional sobre otros
puntos que también están atacando o bien
sobre el tema central de la conversación
que se dio el día de ayer en turquía
para poder establecer si o no un
corredor azul es decir permitir la
salida de estos barcos con más de 25
millones de toneladas
granos que están todavía algunos en
cilindros en los puertos de o deza o
bien
están ya arriba de los barcos sin
embargo atinadamente tú lo decías sí o
sea en realidad esto va a ser el punto
de quiebre para decidir si se rinde
ucrania o si hay un triunfo por el lado
de rusia me parece que todavía estamos
muy lejos de ver que ya en un plazo
inmediato haya una claridad sobre quién
va a ganar y finalmente es el bueno el
plazo a preguntarle por el punto de
partida sobre la importancia de ese
perdón y es que lo que significaría para
rusia un triunfo en esa consolidación de
su presencia en la región del tomba si
lo que significaría para ucrania saludo
entonces en lisboa a marcos farías
ferreira ya no presentaba yo muchas
gracias y bienvenido al programa gracias
por estar con nosotros multiplicado
señor farías
bueno cuál es su opinión en torno a lo
que significa severodonezk para este
punto de la guerra
bueno buenas buenas tardes santiago
buenas tardes a los oyentes
severo donestsk y el donbass en general
son muy importantes en la política
identitaria de de rusia me gustaría
recordar que en un primer momento el
objetivo estratégico de moscú no era
ocupar territorio el objetivo
estratégico era más bien suscribir el
régimen en el jr evitar una guerra y
transformar políticamente el país y de
esta manera
y conseguir sus objetivos de
neutralidad de ucrania y evitar que
ucrania pudiera unirse a la otan sobre
sobre todo es solo en un segundo momento
en el que rusia no consigue
políticamente sus objetivos y tiene que
girar hacia otra estrategia una
estrategia de guerra una estrategia
mucho
mucho más difícil y con muchos más
costes
que es la estrategia de ocupación en
territorial en ese sentido el donbass
iceberg o nets son las zonas
fundamentales para conseguir un
territorio de continuidad entre el
territorio ruso y el territorio de
crimea que rusia ocupó en el 2014 ese es
un punto fundamental como una
digamos un plan b o un objetivo de
segunda línea
en un momento en que rusia no ha
conseguido su objetivo principal de
sustituir el régimen en claro señor
farías en ese orden de ideas de acuerdo
a esta explicación que usted hace rusia
entonces se detiene a lograr capturar la
región del donbass conseguir ese
corredor que le permite unir su
territorio a través de las costas del
mar de azov hasta la península de crimea
o rusia continúa hasta llegar a
transnistria y tal vez ocupar partes del
centro de ucrania cuál es su análisis
pues es un gran interrogante muy muy
importante y por qué porque todas todas
las guerras son dinámicas o sea él
el proceso de la guerra crea sus propias
dinámicas y puede cambiar los objetivos
de los actores en el juego o sea
dependiendo de la
capacidad de
y alcanzar sus objetivos rusia puede
entender que tiene toda la
ventaja de seguir con la guerra por
ejemplo para ocupar odessa y terminar de
conquistar toda la costa de ucrania esto
sería estratégicamente
devastador para ucrania quedarse sin
costa quedar claro sin una salida al mar
negro y para rusia sería importante
teóricamente por lo menos conseguir este
objetivo
llegar a ese territorio
transnistria un territorio poblado de
porcón con una población rusa o ruso
fila donde están
fuerzas armadas claro usas y eso eso
podría ser un objetivo estratégico claro
siguiente sí sí rápidamente rusia
consigue consigue dominar el donbass con
otra cosa todo depende también de la
reacción de los aliados de ucrania o sea
éste forcejeó siempre depende de la
voluntad política de occidente de enviar
nuevas armas armas con malla mayor
alcance o armas con mayor capacidad eso
ya vamos a analizar en la parte de
occidente la posición que tienen algunos
países europeos frente a lo sucedido
esta semana pasó a preguntarle a la
doctora contreras sobre esta pregunta
que le hacía a marcos y se detiene rusia
al conquistar el donbass se detiene en
ese punto trataría de ir un poco más
allá
en la otra cara de la moneda vemos al
presidente selenski diciendo y
prometiéndole a los ucranianos que
recuperaría todo el territorio perdido a
qué costo y con ayuda de quién porque
también vemos a las tropas ucranianas
demostrando síntomas de cansancio de
agotamiento baja moral y también en
cierta forma con una escasez de recursos
a nivel técnico militar
totalmente santiago y me parece que
hasta antes del día 1 de la guerra
posiblemente veríamos que rusia se
conformaría con una negociación con
respecto a donbass hoy conforme ha
venido pasando el tiempo de repente las
señales de la ofensiva militar rusa nos
muestra y nos deja claro en este tablero
que no precisamente ya nada más le
interesa putin la región de donbass sino
que está dispuesto a irse a esta
conexión esta franja al sur que conecta
crimea con ucrania pero también
inclusive moviéndose a odessa de tal
suerte que justamente vaya
asfixiando al no permitirles de acceso
al mar estamos viendo que el
financiamiento eeuu cada espacio ucrania
ha sido clave en cuestión de recursos
económicos pero también es clave todo el
equipo militar el cual se está
comprometiendo alemania y otros países
miembros de la unión europea para poder
equipar y que entonces la defensiva
ucraniana pueda estar al mismo nivel y
no en esto que atinadamente tu
puntualizadas el cansancio la falta de
municiones la falta de tecnología para
poder hacer frente a esta guerra que
cada vez se prolonga día con día y que
cada vez vemos mucho más lejano que
puedan llegarse a acuerdos de paz o sea
si estamos viendo que rusia ahora dice
que negociaría a liberar a pasos y
corredores a cambio de que se levanten
las sanciones entonces me parece
importante plantear sobre la mesa que
ahora rusia va a exigir mucho más y ya
no está dispuesto a renunciar menos por
menos sino que ahora ya su nivel de
negociación su tope cada vez se eleva
más cuando se sienta sobre la mesa a
negociar entonces ahora estamos viendo
que occidente su forma de poder
contrarrestar esto es únicamente a
abonar a la guerra en lugar de que
estemos viendo acuerdos o compromisos o
una mesa de negociación para poder
llegar a la paz eso es lo que me
preocupa porque durante las últimas
semanas únicamente ya hablamos de las
regiones atacadas de guerra de
problemáticas pero no vemos de una
posibilidad de hablar de cómo se puede
negociar con rusia si sus puntos rojos
de el 23 de febrero han cambiado si
ahora sus líneas rojas ya son más y
entonces cabe de un más distante y que
pueda terminar pronto esta guerra
santiago doctora contreras y yo añado
otro y otro ingrediente a esa
preocupación en cuanto a la presión que
está ejerciendo rusia en el conflicto
sobre ucrania y sobre occidente y es el
tema de los cereales precisamente tener
esos puertos del mar de azov y de parte
del mar negro impedirle a ucrania sacar
estos productos en esta temporada del
verano le ha permitido no sé cómo lo ve
usted en términos estratégicos sofocar
la economía ucraniana no tiene como
financiarse para ayudar en la guerra y
ayudar
económicamente en otros aspectos ese
país y también está poniendo al mundo
entero no es solamente a europa oa su
zona influencia al mundo entero al borde
de una crisis alimentaria por la escasez
de alimentos los organismos
internacionales lo han dicho así putin
tiene al mundo en vilo esto yo creo que
en el kremlin se esperaba que fueran a
tener ese poder para poder tener un
margen de negociación aquí que se está
jugando putin que tanto a presionar nos
llevará a rusia a una hambruna mundial
me encanta tu producto tan provocativa
santiago porque estamos viendo un
escenario donde todavía hace meses atrás
algunos medios internacionales decían
que rusia estaba perdiendo la guerra y
yo dije en aquella ocasión que yo no
estaba tan segura que en realidad rusia
estuviera perdiendo porque estaba
ganando otras batallas es decir pudiera
ser que en el frente militar pudiera
retirarse y perder terreno pero en el
frente energético y en la cuestión de
fertilizantes más los minerales y el
tema de los granos eran batallas que tal
vez en ese momento se veían batallas
pequeñas pero que hoy todas estas
batallas están fortaleciendo la posición
de rusia para negociar es decir tú lo
puntualiza vas muy bien entonces hará
que rusia está delineando y está
abriendo nuevos frentes en estas guerras
paralelas que se dan donde hemos hablado
muchas veces aquí en tu espacio de que
esta es una guerra híbrida y que el tema
económico es un tema clave
en esta situación que estamos viviendo a
nivel internacional donde ahora se
delinea este nuevo escenario
internacional donde ya no sólo hay que
hablar de esta ofensiva y defensiva
militar si no hay que hablar entonces de
cómo rusia saben jugar muy bien sus
fichas con la parte de la dependencia
energética que europa tiene frente a
ella como es que vladimir putin está
moviendo su otra ficha de fortalecer al
rublo que lo está logrando y otra otra
ficha es ok si la seguridad alimentaria
está en peligro y puede entrar en crisis
y cada vez nos podemos acercar a una
posible hambruna mundial entonces
pareciera que quien tiene el control ya
es vladimir putin y no el grano dentro
del territorio ucraniano porque aunque
aunque físicamente no serial es estar en
ucrania no pueden salir porque en el mar
negro hay toda una carga geopolítica
donde hay minas sembradas y donde están
pues está
este frente militar entonces es
interesante si no lo estás poniendo
sobre la mesa porque pareciera que no
pero claro que si hoy función tiene el
mango poli satén como decimos
colocándola en méxico es el patrón y por
lo tanto ahora occidente tiene que
negociar muchos otros frentes para
resolver también estas pantallas opinión
de marcos farías en la ciudad de lisboa
sobre este tema este tema de los
cereales y los granos que rusia pues
tiene preocupado al mundo entero ya
hicimos el análisis en este programa
sobre la repercusión que puede tener esa
crisis alimentaria en la región de
américa latina que está a miles de
kilómetros de la región del donbass y
hasta aquí veríamos las consecuencias
bueno yo yo sí creo que vladimir putin
tiene todas estas frentes estos frentes
de conflicto con él con occidente muy
bien pensadas
yo no no creo que la guerra la haya
pensado en los últimos ocho años pero sí
es verdad que la estrategia de rusia por
lo menos desde 2014 es una estrategia
híbrida para occidente y vladimir putin
tiene un bien consciente que vivimos en
un mundo interdependiente que la
globalización impone límites y
posibilidades a las estrategias de los
estados y sobre todo tiene muy bien
pensada la relación que existe que
existía porque ahora o sea está
cambiando la relación entre rusia y
occidente la la la interdependencia
energética sobre todo en en eurasia y
putin sabía muy bien esta
interdependencia y la globalización
son no ponen obstáculos a la decisión
política y estratégica y también militar
de occidente la
crisis de los cereales es un ejemplo
perfecto de lo que estaba de lo que
estaba diciendo y pone a occidente como
en un dilema fundamental porque una
parte importante de lo que propone putin
para resolver el problema de los
cereales es que se alivien por lo menos
una parte de las sanciones comerciales
por ejemplo de occidente a rusia y en
esto pone la decisión en manos en el
tejado de occidente que hacer
profundizar estas sanciones
no sea
seguir una estrategia rígida de
sanciones con rusia a todo costo con
negociar incluso las sanciones que eran
la parte fundamental de la estrategia de
occidente en nombre de
una estrategia global que pueda resolver
este
la posible hambruna y no sólo la
hambruna las crisis
sociales que van a surgir en una parte
importante del mundo en aceh y en el
áfrica subshariana en medio oriente
por eso esto lo tenga occidente en una
situación en un en un dilema muy difícil
de resolver sin marcos y si hay un país
que ha entendido la dinámica de rusia y
ha entendido muy bien la importancia de
su ubicación geoestratégica es turquía
se ha ofrecido como país mediador entre
occidente ha intentado hablar con rusia
y esta semana fuimos testigos de ese
encuentro en ankara de los dos
cancilleres del canciller turco y el
canciller
de rusia para hablar precisamente del
paso por los estrechos del bósforo y de
los dardanelos que están en territorio
turco de los barcos que puedan salir una
vez se han supuestamente desbloqueado
los puertos ucranianos para sacar parte
de esta cosecha de granos y de cereales
desde ucrania y desde el sur de rusia
aquí turquía qué papel puede jugar qué
tan estratégico está haciendo el
presidente
turco el presidente erdogán
y que puede ganar que puede negociar con
los rusos a cambio de dejar pasar estos
barcos sin problemas y esto no genere
ningún tipo de problema ción bruselas o
en washington bueno la posición de
turquía es una es una posición de
negociar no sólo con rusia pero también
con occidente en turquía es un país de
la otan
pérez es un país que mantiene su
autonomía estratégica eso es fundamental
para para turquía desde hace por lo
menos 10 años
y hay muchos muchos puntos de la agenda
turca de la gente exterior turca que
están en este momento en juego está la
cuestión de cydia porque turquía quiere
[Música]
llevar a cabo una operación en el norte
de siria contra los zurdos kurdos para
establecer una zona de seguridad
en ese escenario que todavía es de
guerra en el norte de turquía y en ese
punto tiene que negociar con rusia
porque hay intereses que pueden ser
complementarios con los de rusia en
siria pero hay una fricción no sea no
son completamente
paralelos o completamente
reconciliables esos intereses o sea
tiene que hablar con rusia para poder
alcanzar su objetivo militar en el norte
de turquía pero con occidente también
tiene que negociar y tiene que negociar
por ejemplo el final del embargo de
armas que eeuu suecia el reino unido le
pusieron hace hace algunos años
justamente por cuestiones de
desde la guerra de decir ya que hay que
negociar también y tiene una tiene un
instrumento fundamental que tiene que
ver con la unión de suecia y finlandia a
la votar en este momento turquía tiene
en su mano la opción de primarias y
finlandia
dentro de la otan ya este punto está
negociando el apoyo lo que dicen es el
apoyo de sobre todo de suecia a los
kurdos a movimientos políticos que
ankara entiende que están en la órbita
del fin entiendo marcos sí para avanzar
rapidísimo el tiempo y me quedan muchos
temas todavía por analizar paso a
preguntarle a la doctora contreras en la
ciudad de méxico avanzó a otro tema y es
ese reclamo que ha hecho turquía que lo
hizo justamente el
representante del parlamento de ucrania
ruslán este pachuca ante el parlamento
de la unión europea en estrasburgo donde
le pidió urgentemente al grupo de estos
27 países que le den aunque ucrania el
estatus de país candidato esto en qué
forma lo puede proteger o beneficiar en
el marco de esta guerra y de esta
invasión de rusia
me parece importante destacar santiago
que ante esta solicitud de digamos un
fast track para que tenga una visión
pues muy próxima estamos viendo que no
es tan fácil es decir las condiciones
actuales y ucrania no permiten ni
siquiera este
solicitud del estado como país que
rápido ya vaya a estar en un proceso la
voluntad existe pero las condiciones
económicas políticas y sociales no le
permiten por el momento
ingresar y eso es un punto que me
regreso tu pregunta anterior que estabas
abordando que tiene que ver con el rol
de turquía tu quien no va a estar para
nada de acuerdo y contento de que si
ucrania logra ingresar a la unión
europea mientras que turquía llega lleva
más de dos décadas intentándolo por eso
también turquía sabe mover muy bien
todas sus fichas de por donde va a
bloquearla suecia finlandia hay una
próxima cumbre de la otan a realizarse a
finales de este mes en la ciudad de
madrid donde se van a tocar estos puntos
regresando al tema
a la voluntad y la petición existe y por
eso es que la unión europea ha estado
dotando de recursos financieros
mecanismos de cooperación y de recepción
a la gran cantidad de 6.5 millones de
refugiados santiago sin embargo creo yo
que al menos en un plazo inmediato no
estaremos viendo a ucrania como miembro
de la unión europea si es que haciendo
análisis de los procesos de adhesión es
la unión europea ucrania era uno de los
países que está más alejado de esos
compromisos que tienen que hacer en
materia de justicia de derechos humanos
de económico si uno lo compara con otros
países que están en el mismo proceso que
le llevan mucha ventaja a ucrania
entonces sería también un muy mal
mensaje para otros países que están
haciendo fila como serbia como bosnia
herzegovina incluso montenegro moldavia
georgia que han hecho ya hace pocas
semanas hacen muy pocas semanas hicieron
su su ingreso oficial como un país
candidato aspirante para hacer parte de
la unión europea también destacado a lo
largo de esta semana fueron esas
declaraciones marcos muy puntual le pido
por favor me queda poco tiempo del
canciller alemán olaf scholz quien
insiste en que la prioridad para europa
en este conflicto es evitar una
confrontación entre rusia y la otan pero
vemos a alemania- rearmándose con un
fondo militar de miles de millones de
euros que va a utilizar en los próximos
cinco años para poder renovar todo su
ejército y sus fuerzas armadas ante la
amenaza que representa el avance de
rusia va a pasar a ser la potencia
militar de europa en solamente cinco
años y veamos a rusia haciendo
ejercicios militares frente a las costas
de kaliningrado justo enfrente de tres
países de la otan los tres estados
bálticos y pues suecia y finlandia al
frente aquí
la mostrada de dientes entre los dos es
claramente entre berlín y moscú como
entender entonces esa posible
confrontación
otan-rusia puede llegar a darse
bueno esas estas de estas dinámicas son
muy difíciles de anticipar es verdad que
hay un compromiso de los países de la
otan desde hace ya varios años de
aumentar los gastos militares al 2% del
pib por lo menos eso ahora si se va a
avanzar había muchas dudas muchas de
citaciones en el pasado ahora sí va a
avanzar claro que hay dilemas de
seguridad que se van alimentando unos a
otros y eso va a pasar o sea el rearme
en base a una realidad dentro de la otan
fuera de la otan y sobre todo en el
desarrollo de una política europea de
defensa autónoma esa va a ser la
cuestión principal cómo se va a
desarrollar una política europea de
defensa autónomamente en cara a la otan
o complementaria en relación a la votar
por otro lado hay otra cuestión
fundamental que no pasa por por la
cuestión militar que tiene que ver con
los ejes de poder en la unión europea
todos sabemos qué
desde su principio en la unión europea
el eje principal de poder que mueve las
agendas las prioridades es el eje parís
berlín con esta guerra y con con la
profundización de la guerra yo creo que
se está viendo muy bien el surgimiento
de un eje varsovia kiev en ucrania no es
parte de la unión europea pero ya está
monopolizando la agenda de la unión
europea y puede que lo monopolice en los
próximos años y esto puede hacer surgir
con mucha realidad un eje de poder de
capacidad de imponer una agenda en un
eje en varsovia mins que puede cambiar
mucho lo que es la unión la unión
europea y esta brecha dentro de la unión
europea va a ser muy importante en el
largo o sea hay una tensión muy grande
entre parís y berlín por un lado que
quieren una solución diplomática
la guerra porque beben entienden que hay
que
comprender hay que reconstituir la
relación con la rusia de putin 6 post
pudding y hay otra parte de polonia
ucrania a los países bálticos que
quieren una ruptura total con rusia como
si rusia no existiera como si se pudiera
cambiar la geografía claro y ahí
entraría a polonia hacer esa especie de
estado colchón entre un lado y el otro
que es lo que en muchos casos se pensó
que podía llegar a ser ucrania en un
momento pero pero ya pues claramente a
rusia fue más allá de las fronteras
opinión de la doctora contreras sobre
este tema sobre esta amenaza esta
posible confrontación y estos cambios de
ejes políticos en la unión europea y le
añado un tema que analizamos justamente
en el programa del rearme de alemania y
es el fin del pacifismo alemán y el fin
de la neutralidad de finlandia suecia y
suiza
así es interesante ver que ahora suecia
y finlandia le han dado todo un giro a
su política exterior de neutralidad al
solicitar formalmente su ingreso al
hotal aunque se enfrentan ante el
posible veto de turquía el tema de la
neutralidad de suiza es interesante
santiago porque te puedo decir que en
una ocasión todo el partido platicar con
el embajador de suiza aqui en mexico y
en lo que me compartía y lo puedo decir
porque no es algo confidencial es que
suiza siente cree
no está violentando su política de
neutralidad sino que simplemente está
sumándose al tema de las sanciones sin
que esto signifique ni que está alineado
a occidente no es miembro de la unión
europea nunca va a ingresar algo tan
simple y sencillamente lo consideran
como medidas necesarias al interior de
su país pero no porque tengan alguna
alineación hacia occidente retomando la
continuidad de los de los ejes me parece
también importante no perder de vista el
eje bielorrusia hungría totalmente
alineados a rusia es decir hungría es
miembro de la unión europea de hecho
este tardar mucho en negociar el tema
del sexto paquete de sanciones de queda
dejar la dependencia energética porque
hungría pidió una excepción de que fuera
lo más prolongado posible puesto que
hungría depende totalmente de los
energéticos de rusia y porque hay una
gran afinidad de ideologías políticas
entre lukashenko computing entonces ahí
también estamos teniendo otros y que a
lo mejor no tiene el mismo peso para
hacer un contrapeso no estaba en la
balsa pero no podemos perderlo de vista
entonces aquí también los ejes que tiene
mucho que ver de manera digamos
virtuales pues son como lo que tiene que
ver con los energéticos y los granos
pues hacia donde también se están
alineando las las fichas y hacia dónde
se están volcando los intereses
geopolíticos pero también económicos de
la región donde no precisamente a veces
las decisiones de occidente son las
mejores para lucrar
pero esperemos que en ese juego no
veamos a hungría tratando de recuperar
territorios y regiones perdidos donde
hay húngaro parlantes donde
históricamente hungría fue el país
predominante y que no quieren recuperar
esto como lo está haciendo rusia en este
momento en supuesta defensa de los rusos
parlantes o los étnicamente eslavos que
hay en estas regiones que están siendo
invadidas en este momento importante
para ya para este tramo final del
programa hablar del presidente putin el
presidente de la federación de rusia
cada semana analizamos cómo está su
imagen al interior del país la
perspectiva que hay de los ciudadanos y
a nivel internacional
estos movimientos esta presión por el
tema de los cereales de los puertos de
la posible hambruna que factura le
pueden pasar a nivel internacional al
presidente ruso marcos muy puntual por
favor porque me quedan pocos minutos
bueno yo creo que
putin y sus allegados los intereses que
se mueven alrededor del régimen de putin
tienen
y clara esta idea de que la imagen
internacional no es muy importante o sea
no es importante la imagen junto de
occidente porque se asume con esta
guerra
un choque
existencial con occidente pero
entiende que es muy importante la imagen
de putin junto por ejemplo de los países
emergentes y la imagen de
dirigente de líder de
capacidad política para alcanzar sus
objetivos políticos
puede ser
aumentada en países como brasil como la
india como china o sea que la figura la
persona de putin puede salir reforzada
en el sentido de que es un dirigente
político que sabe utilizar
estratégicamente varios frentes de
conflicto con las potencias hegemónicas
en este conflicto conflicto entre las
potencias hegemónicas y las potencias
emergentes es algo que rusia la política
exterior de rusia siempre ha querido
jugar desde la llegada de putin en el
2000 se ha rusia y putting personalmente
ser magnífica esa lucha contra la
hegemonía de eeuu de occidente y esta es
la batalla final o una batalla
fundamental para los países emergentes
si me queda un minuto doctora contreras
adelante su conclusión en torno al tema
del presidente putin y la presión
internacional que pueda haber sobre él
la marca-país sucia está totalmente
pulverizada y sin duda la imagen de
vladimir putin está únicamente
fortalecida en algunos sectores al
interior de esta nación pero me parece
que a nivel internacional está
verdaderamente ligado a cuestiones
negativas así que más adelante pues
únicamente estará contando con el apoyo
de china al interior del consejo de
seguridad de la onu y también tendrá que
después partir de -0 para poder
construir nuevas alianzas en un
escenario en posguerra y hago muchas
gracias
pues a la doctora maribel contreras en
la ciudad de mexico y a marcos varias
ferreira en la ciudad de lisboa en
portugal les agradezco por haber hecho
este análisis de los más recientes
hechos en torno a la guerra en ucrania
ya lo saben los jueves estamos haciendo
habitualmente este tipo de análisis
sobre los temas concernientes a este
esta guerra en el este de europa muchas
gracias pueden seguir dejando ustedes
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales y pueden
seguir en sintonía de france24 sigan con
nosotros
[Música]